my name is Rex power cool I'm a cyber
commando mark for designation my mission
is to protect and serve the United
States
for the past decade the US and day has
been at war
communist Empire of Vietnam
it's the fourth war we fought against
them
but this one's different just the Reds
have managed to master blood dragon tech
I don't understand and I don't give a
[ __ ] how they did it I'm just here to
shoot
what I get is the tapping blood dragons
for energy and turning their blood in
the weapons we can't stand that's why
they sent the best of the best of the
best to end it once and for all who won
the bike That's not me
Brett's Colts been gone for nine years
that's one of my kids
kids twelve years ago I fell for a lady
dr. Elizabeth darling it was beautiful
woman I ever saw we got married had
twins together a boy and a girl girls
name is Roxanne she's a smart one you
want something done stealthy with a
light touch you called her and the boy
here Slater
best rider I've ever seen totally
fearless hell of a shot nine years ago I
went to [ __ ]
what disappeared left me left us not
even a note just vanished
me I couldn't look at the kids because
every time I did it reminded me of her I
look for her everywhere
she was gone so I feel the dam and I
[ __ ] that damn war by myself
guess what lost the reticle you knew
there's no more the good thing was
general Mason Ryback came along to take
care of them once I was gone turn them
into cyber commandos to march Six's
latest tech hiding all cybernetics under
living tissues it only makes sense for
my kids to follow daddy's footsteps
let's lay there on a mission to rescue
POWs just like I would have I couldn't
be proud of what those kids are about to
do
corporal colt this mission is of the
utmost importance
some of our soldiers have been taken
prisoner by the because we are of
America we leave no man behind
our objective in mayhem is simple normal
we need to put to helm the commies
commander if we rattle the cage enough
the Beast will come out the open that
will not be easy
he's a cautious man but if we need to
stabilize the region of Nam that'll draw
fill Shores damn
hell all we have to do is locate and
termini
this
we eliminate bad guys on this one is no
corporal
play some of us are studying for an
exhibition so if s are studying for a
next mission
whatever you say mom I'm not your mom
under sister okay
that was totally badass if you'd studied
you to be no one how to dodge that you
know this for total nerd you're alright
and for a bratty younger brother by six
minutes you're okay too